[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous avons face à nous tant de candidats
qui peut être n'ont pas le sens ne
souhaite pas redire le sens de cette
civilisation
nous avons élu un président de la
république qui nous avions qu'il n'y a
pas de culture française alors il a beau
parler aujourd'hui de l'art d'être
français disons lui que le plus beau des
arts c'est d'abord de savoir pour
recevoir cette culture qui nous
précèdent et que nous avons à offrir à
tous ceux qui nous suivront
et dans cette campagne des européennes
il y a une seule liste et dynamique
il ya une seule vie ce qui donne de
l'envié il ya une seule vie ce
qu'affirment ses idées il ya une soliste
et et 2006 est capable à ce point-là
d'élever le niveau et le débat c'est la
nôtre dans cette campagne des
européennes qu'il ya une seule liste qui
déjoue les pronostics
une seule liste qui s'affirme c'est
celle des républicains et du centre je
suis tiers du chemin que vous voulez
[Musique]
nous rencontrons oui bien manger
civilisation imagine de france
oui bien l'épisode wii bien un jour
invité à plusieurs hôtels et nous avons
donné c'est son bonnet les nouveaux
besoins variés la vie dans une europe au
service de la france que nous avons
besoin de rétablir ensemble refonder
l'europe pour rétablir la france 27
jours pour relever ce grand défi
je compte sur vous merci un tournage il
ya une volonté tout d'un coup de parler
à nouveau avoir honte
il y as envie de re dire avec fierté ce
que nous sommes et ce que nous voulons
être il y a quelque chose qui se passe
dans cette campagne
alors nous avons besoin de vous françois
xavier a besoin de vous
chacun de ceux qui sont ici sur cette
liste ont besoin de nous nous avons 27
jours et 27 jours pour convaincre 27
jours pour déjouer les pronostics
27 jours pourrait affirmer avec fierté
ce que nous sommes 27 jours pour porter
ce qui est le plus beau des combats
quand on fait de la politique redonner
un avenir à notre civilisation retourner
tout à la fois l'europe et rétablir la
france libre la mordre et les blancs au
verre
[Musique]
à
oh
non
[Musique]
et
à
ouais
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]